tonight a sports scientist who worked
with oscar pistorius describes how the
sportsman overcame his broken body and
triumphed as an athlete and out crossing
the finishing line in competing in abled
body competition represents his triumph
over his disability and the prosecution
tries to discredit his evidence in
fierce cross-examination those
experiences with mr. Pistorius that
would be character evidence and not
experience welcome to the high court in
Pretoria well we've heard in great
detail from a sport scientist who worked
with Oscar Pistorius for six years
professor Wayne Derman described what
it's like living with prosthetic legs
emphasizing that disability never sleeps
he also spoke of the two Oscars the
athletes who could take on the
able-bodied with a never-say-die
attitude but also the vulnerable
disabled man who admitted he would be
stuffed without his prosthesis professor
durman's report was seized on by
prosecutor Harry nel who accused the
witness of giving contradictory
statements and questioned his expertise
Skye's Paul Harrison reports arriving by
car adjusting the trousers over his
prosthetic legs a subconscious yet
poignant action by Oscar Pistorius who
took his seat in court to hear his
colleague and Sport scientist tell judge
Massey / not having lower legs was the
source of the Paralympians daily
vulnerability although mr. Pistorius has
dedicated his life to fight against
discrimination against disability and he
loathes to be pitied in any way the hard
truth is that he does not have lower
legs we don't really understand it and
I'm including myself in it and I'm
saying that I don't think even that I'm
the best person to try and explain this
to you because I do not have something
called a lived experience I am not the
same
I don't have a lived experience of
ability and in order to truly understand
it you need a loved experience of
disability you've got a paradox of an
individual who is supremely able and
you've got a individual who is
significantly disabled and that template
of him with his arms out crossing the
finishing line and competing in abled
body competition represents his triumph
over his disability and that template is
what he holds up to hold up to perform
against each and every day when you are
with artist ups without your prosthesis
one also assumes that that is the only
time that you are vulnerable that
doesn't that doesn't impact on issues to
do when you have got your prosthesis on
milady that is not true
disability impacts nearly every aspect
of one's life through the words of
amputees themselves professor Durman
then sought to highlight the daily
hurdles faced by all those who have lost
limbs it gets stared at constantly loss
of confidence with self-esteem
self-image often were self-conscious a
lifetime issue staring has a detrimental
effect on those of us people sometimes
feel uncomfortable for us people ask
questions people make judgments on your
disability before they know you they
slow to make friends often you excluded
social issues in communal bathrooms
showers are famed of never being able to
shower in public opening bottles of
shampoo shower gel because you have to
have one hand on a handrail all the time
in order to balance difficulty getting
dressed prosthetic legs or bulky it
takes much more time to put these on
there's a bad odor of the legs which
makes for embarrassment this is a
problem on a plane
sharing room with somebody etcetera
there are many issues to do with
intimacy that I don't feel that the
is the forum to actually go into but you
can imagine personal intimate
relationships in the home generally on
the couch without a prosthetic legs for
example one is not able to reach
cellphone quickly for on-screen if not
next to you while sleeping it takes
effort to go to the bathroom to have a
shower before putting on the prosthetic
legs has to be done every time because
of not able to react quickly to
anything they have a sense of fear in
the house etc not able to protect
oneself or spouse when something happens
extreme vulnerability without prosthetic
legs for the postman or delivery etc
takes a long time to open the door not
comfortable hosting anyone for coffee
not even friends when without prosthetic
legs it has a knock-on effect through
one's entire function and the saddest
thing that I have learned milady in my
experience of now six years working with
athletes with disability is that
disability never sleeps it's there when
you go to sleep at night and it's there
when you wake up in the morning
defending Oscar Pistorius Kenny Aldridge
quoted from the psychologists report
pointing to the two Oscars one being the
never-say-die confident superstar the
other the man measuring less than 1.5
meters in height who felt stuffed
without his prosthetic legs quote his
but using his body in space to run and
jump and climb gave him a sense of
confidence in his physical abilities and
probably partially rehabilitated his
view of quote me as a broken body
unquote and then I turned to deal with
the contents of page 28 headlines 22 to
I believe the construction of quote the
two
oscar's unquote i referred to earlier
finally gelled into a final split the
one oscar being an international
superstar more confident and feeling
more in control at one point eight four
meters tall that part of him falling
back on his physicality and quote
never-say-die unquote
attitude that it served him so well
although not completely at ease he felt
this vulnerable in that state the other
oscar being a vulnerable and fearful
disabled person at less than 1.5 meters
once his prosthesis were removed and he
was alone at night that part of him
falling back onto his anxiety and fear
not feeling in control with his
prosthesis on many people can damage him
but without them he feels defenseless
quote I am stuffed
without my legs on unquote the trial of
Oscar Pistorius may have begun four
months ago today but in that time the
legal teams often direct approach has
far from softened as prosecutor Harry
nel showed as he attempted to discredit
the so-called expert witness I listened
to what you said you said my beef was to
share my experiences with mr. Pistorius
now those experiences with mr. Pugh
stories that would be character evidence
and not experience no because it's in
relevance my knowledge of him with
respect to any of my knowledge in
disabilities or the fact that I am a
sport in exercise medicine physician who
has knowledge of the other responses
that might be in play
your main responsibility is to act in
the best interest of your client or your
your patient am i right yes sir
is that what you're doing now our
beliefs are now what did you say that an
expert witness would require high sense
of objectivity to be able to assist the
court in any way indeed I would sir but
that you don't have because objectivity
may harm your client your patient I'm
not going to come before this court
giving a and I understand mr. Nell's
inferences one of bias a biased report
because I have been very very careful my
lady to back up with scientific evidence
all of the points that I have made I
would not risk my reputation being here
by coming to bring bias and a biased
report I cannot do this to suggest to
professor Terman
that he's here only to serve his
patients best interests by virtue of the
doctor-patient relationship what mr.
nail should have done so as to prevent a
misunderstanding or a misleading
statement is to have said to Professor
Thurman in a medical context insofar as
the relationship between patient and
doctor goes you must serve your clients
best interests at all times that we
understand to be the code of good
practice governing physicians and their
patients not in the context of him
having to serve his clients best
interests here in court today
it's a misleading statement the
objection is sustained
thank you money coming up prosecutor
Harry Nell puts pressure on pistorius's
response to the startled
welcome back this morning a sports
scientist described how there were two
sides to Oscar Pistorius and the impact
of living with a disability he then
faced a harder line of questioning over
his relationship with mr. Pistorius mr.
Pistorius in this particular instance is
more than a patient of those MRI I've
been saying that I'm uncertain what you
mean but do you think it's more of a
patient see just a patient like all your
other patients are you closer to him
have you had more contact with him that
then you will have with a normal patient
patient no not my lady not at all there
are a group of athletes in Cape Town
that in Stellenbosch a group of
Paralympians that are spending much more
time with then I've spent with mr.
Pistorius and indeed or closer to in my
working relationship then mr. Pistorius
so we know this incorrect but what we
have is we have you describe your
relationship if no I mean for six years
that's number one - you've got to know
him by virtue of periodical health
assessments at Summit milady is pair of
16 page four of Morten number three
either yet direct observations of your
patient during medical consultations
both formal and informal number four as
well as my observation of him within the
close confines of us residing together
that's far as in a team number six is an
apparent second paragraph
I've spent significant amount of taoism
Pistorius in the anti-doping and you
made it here that at paragraph 15 I have
an intimate knowledge of my patient mr.
Pistorius
so the person giving evidence about you
have an intimate knowledge of and a
direct relationship I would also say
that there are a number of other
athletes that I have also learnt about
and I don't want to use the names but
the more successful and athlete is the
more you're going to learn about them
because you're going to accompany them
into the anti-doping environment doctor
Durman said he'd spoken to Pistorius on
two occasions about what happened on
February the 14th last year because he
wanted to hear it for himself but his
recording of these events came under
scrutiny my lady I have explained to mr.
Knoll that there were two occasions that
I met with mr. Pistorius and this here
how it is a paper recorded the events of
the 14th of February is how I recollect
and I understood the events to be
exactly when I wrote the suck I I don't
have you see the question was just easy
I asked you when you said it must have
been before now I'm asking the question
it must have been before what before I
met with him the second time you wrote
this down before you meet with him a
second time are you sure I'm not quite
sure you see that is my problem you this
expert you are did guide the court you
don't take notes you're not quite sure
the expert convicts that answer
professor you must be quite sure well
sir this is how I understand it this is
my recollection of the two occasions
that if there is something specific that
you disagree with in this then I welcome
your question please professor I will
direct questions as I would like to sir
can you not tell us when you recorded 46
and 47 before the trial started or they
often
it must be when the trial had started
okay it must be when the trial that
started so that means it must have been
a week before mr. stories were seen for
observation no sir that's that's not
that's not discussed with you that this
has been over a long period of time
confusion seemed to reign over how many
audible startles all noises there were
with the witness being accused of
contradicting himself and please if you
don't understand address it to the court
I'm dealing with a contradiction in your
evidence that's all a contradiction
insane
I would expected the second startle
further after right now by saying a con
say why would you have those two
contradictory answers in a question of
an hour
well the idea I don't believe that as
answers with contradictory he mister now
put it to me that in if the was once
bottle and the that culminated in all of
the events that ended up in the shooting
would that be outside the flight in
flight response that's our understood
that question to me to to be put to me
and the answer is I don't know I can't
say that that would be because you would
need to measure you would need to
measure the sympathetic nervous system
at that time but initially you said you
they you would require a second a
subsequent startled because of the lapse
of time and I'm what do you to explain
that because there were two further
noises which were the starters no sir
I'm not dealing with the do further and
and you cannot get away from this
professor you yourself said you would
expect a second startle and that's all
I'm asking you why did you say that
initially my lady because there was a
second startle no you see professor as
an expert that that question is
interesting you yourself clarified the
fact that you were referring to the
other two starttls remember you said I
now understand I'm I was forget about
that am i right
I was not take that into account
am i right my lady I mister Nell has got
me very confused I am really sticking by
what I have said here about the fact
that there were two other startle
responses and that what I was referring
to and I'm sorry I can't assist further
no unfortunately professor it's not that
easy today we've been given an insight
into the psychological and physical
challenges of wearing prosthetics by the
last witness in this trial sports
scientist professor Wayne Derman dr.
Durman who worked with Oscar Pistorius
for six years described himself as an
expert witness a definition prosecutor
Harry nel tried to discredit well to
discuss today's evidence I'm joined by
the psychologists on New Yor Dan and the
criminal attorney Ike Matlin thank you
both
Sonia first of all we heard a lot from
the professor about this fight-or-flight
response particularly in terms of a
disabled person the suggestion is that
it was the fight responses that kicked
in that Oscar Pistorius chose to go
towards the day it is possible that you
know what it's also you must also
remember that you act on stuff that is
known to
he was used to act when he ran to listen
for the shot so that was his response
his first response probably after never
speak James I can't say that but I know
that is a very normal response
especially for athletes I what about
this issue of trying to show that there
was a reason for Oscar Pistorius going
towards the danger it's an important
issue for the defense isn't it it all
leaves me cold I'll tell you why that
two reasons one you see when you call
expert witnesses you call them so that
they can support your case in other
words Oscar should have made out the
case rest which they must then come in
some hot they can't make out the case
for him now the question is what's
Oscar's case started off as a protective
self defense it mutated into automatism
it had subtle inferences of mental
illness the question is what's his case
you can call all all experts of the
world but them I support your case I can
make out the case for you so you're
saying that this witness's is to shore
up their case very late in the child let
me tell you why the evidence of
Professor them and in particular has
left me cold and that fight or flight
thing I think in his own weight is not
an exact science
okay and and Oscar is not testified
about the fight of fight flight mode so
whose case are they putting up so and
and and and in criminal proceedings you
can't pull out the rabbit out of the
head right at the end if it was their
case then by the time the state closed
its case after the bout is it 20
witnesses that the state called that
then that fight or flight mode should
have been put to one of those witnesses
as Howie as a reason
explanation Boise Sania even if they
raised this fight all fliers say palm
prove that that was prompting his act
now they can't because they don't know
what what his thoughts were but it is
not exact science I fully agree but you
know out of many years of working with
people like this you know there is that
that instant moment of freeze and if
there was a shot or assault or anything
that was the that was the point of
fighting but even if it was due to if he
thought that river was in difficult that
could be a very very for me valuable
point well thank you both for your
insights as we know the trial is still
continuing the court won't sit tomorrow
the cross-examination of Professor Wayne
durman will continue instead on Monday
you can prepare for that by watching our
roundup of this week's defense case with
a special program of the weekend
for now though goodbye from Pretoria
you